hey everyone welcome back to the game
squad stage here at e3 2017 live and
joining myself and Dave is out pickin
from the Creative Assembly good evening
welcome to Brit the British are here is
it all three of us here in force we're
taking over to talk about total war
Warhammer - al what's the show been like
for you
fantastic particularly given I think
that it's um it's open to the public
again this year yes it's been absolutely
round very buzzy and yeah mazing really
yeah a little jungle down there yeah you
got a great bit yeah yeah we have here
got jungle we've got a the the
eight-foot head of a connoisseur hanging
over the stand ready to bite people in
the head so what one for my living the
canals yeah yeah pretty much
so I understand you've got a battle
you're gonna walk us through eating the
Lizard Men and the high oh yes this is
the battle we've had playable at the at
the show it's called Battle of Fallen
gates and it's a quest battle for croc
girl who's one of the legendary dogs
that's playable for the lizard Ben when
you play can't wait all right let's take
a look yeah so this is kind of the this
help right to start the battle you start
with a small force and you see croc car
riding the connoisseur which is the
t-rex style beastie down there in the
middle chap attack yeah exactly and and
this is this is actually a new battle
type cetera to Warhammer that we've
we've sort of used in historic
appearance before we would have built
into Warhammer it said checkpoint back
so the whole point is there's that
there's a major checkpoint on the map so
whoever you know if this was a
procedural battle between two armies
that you would generate on the campaign
map then obviously everyone's going to
want to kind of try and control that
choke that's a good kind of hot gate set
up to to defend you put you put all you
know your toughest melee troops along
that bridge to a defender and coming for
all your archers behind effectively so
but in this situation it's the Lizardman
we have to
to reach the bridgehead speaking so all
the beasties charging in full pelt and
they do a lot I actually sing no they've
got they pretty much every turn attack
they do is an AoE splash damage attack
which knocks loads of guys flying over
so so this isn't section just sort of
after after the bridge were they they've
been there way past the first health of
defenders and they're sort of cresting
the hill here you see the Dragons just
blowing it's fire breath down there so
we dragons
you know we had them in Tokyo or
Warhammer but they didn't have breath
attack so we've now given all dragon
breath tax so they're much more
multi-role now they can do you know big
flame damage yeah man lovely we've got
quite a few new sinks animations like
combat animations between large versus
large as so both those guys have special
attacks against each other and special
combat moves so the details white in the
face the classic tale swiping the face
there and you'll see yeah you'll see
you'll see the connoisseur shoulder
barge the dragon to the ground at points
it's really good fun lizard men look
like you've always had monstrous units
Bert and that's into your core things
yeah it's really it's really kind of
what they're all about and it's funny I
don't I don't think other thing lizard
men are perhaps one of the better-known
races in the Warhammer world and
whenever we've shown people this they've
just been you know humming the Jurassic
Park scene to you yeah
and yeah and just laughing with glee
when they see those those masses those
high mass units smashing into our units
of sort of rank and file troops there's
a lot of kind of red red angry flashing
going on there since those those units
there are certain units especially fear
all units in the Lizardman army when
when they've taken enough damage and
they get angry enough they they go rogue
basically and they go like I'd lost
yeah exactly they just put charge
pell-mell towards the nearest enemy and
in order to eat them essentially so this
is one of the one of them is immense
well the saw flying skirmish unit really
they called tarragon's and these guys
are fantastic for zipping around and
taking out arches in the back of the
enemy line or or actually ganged up like
this they can actually do quite a lot of
sort of collateral damage at the same
time to play they have what you see what
you seen flying there or five each bolus
thing but mad little creatures that are
sort of buried buried in the jungle
which they which they dig up and throw
around and basically work like a form of
magical napalm and they can also drop
bombs as well as you get the reticle pop
up when you want to drop the bomb and
then they can they they carry you know
big lumps of rock into battle with them
so you've got a couple of rock attacks
that they can do throughout the course
of the battle so soften them up with the
the fire these bowl ash and then you
know drop a load of rocks on them and
they are melting time zone yeah and so
you know it's a relatively large armored
unit like this they'll see their couple
units so these guys will see them off
real quick and when it comes to it you
know they're out of ammo you could
charge them in as well you know they're
not the best melee units in the world
but they they they will you know they
will cause a unit to think twice imagine
about where is standing or coming at you
yeah exactly flapping away they don't
have very big you know from a distance
and then you put them next to a single
unit anything
nobody want low a nice [ __ ] [ __ ]
face yeah so yeah that's the that's the
Terra Don's so that was just a brief you
know that was just a few sections of
that battle that the whole battle lasts
about 15 minutes and we've got a play
ball here on the show floor we've got an
easy version for newcomers to South war
and a hard version which I've never seen
anyone do better than a Pyrrhic victory
at so far which so it's a good challenge
and that's why I got a very victory yeah
what as good as I used to be its it but
I'm you saying that so that's a quest
battle what can you tell us about the
reason and the actual battle itself so
it's it's it's kind of a chat what
almost a challenge or a rite of passage
battle for for crop gar and it's
delivered by Mazda Mundi who's the who's
the the oldest of the living slam made
priests and I think that frog people
might have seen exactly that the
floating toad on the throne yeah and
he's he essentially gives this quest to
the croc guard to go and prove himself
and he gets a he gets a you know a
unique magical item at the end of it so
he's got several stages to go through
like quest battles we have in the game
which culminates in that big battle
there and what and the whole objective
there is the High Elves have turned up
there they're kind of diddling around in
this ancient site of power that was that
was it's essentially an ancient
teleporter for the old ones who who were
the gods the the sort of the the
earliest gods who actually created the
Liz have been the first race of the war
kind of world and they used to zip
around the universe using using
teleporters and giant pyramid spaceships
so so that's like that's the very very
early days of the Warhammer universe
they're not around anymore but all these
relics are left behind so the High Elves
come along they sense some kind of
magical energy there and there is
immense pot that they're digging around
in the ruins and they're like we should
know noob not know so they're there
that's the quest that's the ultimate
objective that quest battle is to is to
oust the Hales from their actually
activities so how is the world different
now because so all Warhammer one it was
almost kind of recognizable the way the
humans have involved and it was all kind
of connected to history as you could
recognize like swords and armor but now
it's dragons now yes Arkells and by
visits how is that change that will have
a
world notes even more eclectic than the
previous one was so in a number of ways
really I mean all the races all the
playable races are in in a kind of in a
race so to speak to control the great
vortex which is a giant magical sort of
tornado that sits on all fun which is
the islands the homeland of the High
Elves and they're all after that so
they're all in there all intention to
get it and what that creates is
throughout the throughout the the
narrative of the campaign you're you're
you're performing these these rituals
and hoping you can keep them going for a
few turns that you need to keep them
going for being attacked and then that
gets you one step closer to dominating
the vortex and achieving your sort of
ultimate victory conditions and
throughout that it really brings those
races together and you start seeing the
differences between them and we've
really I mean one of the you know one of
the things that we did with the first
game which initially was a bit of an
experiment
fingers crossed how people like this was
to make the races completely different
and write and have fewer but much deeper
races with much different company you
know vastly different campaign mechanics
and that worked very very differently in
battle you know and you know to be
honest the tabletop game just gives us
that and the army books we know that
those armies are going to play
differently but reflecting that in the
design for their campaign game mechanics
is very important as well and we that
worked really well so we're doing more
of that we're doing that more so than we
even that we did in the first one so so
the various the various races have have
completely unique mechanics such as the
lizard men can access the single the
geomantic web which is a sort of ancient
network of ley lines that runs or it
runs beneath the surface of the earth it
all set up with the old ones back in the
old days and and and they can they can
re-energize these by capturing cities
that connect across these ley lines they
can reenergize them and it brings like
some some really major bonuses to those
settlements and their ability to raise
resources raise taxes and that sort of
thing and defend themselves as well so
they can really they can really exploit
the landscape in a way that no other
race can you know so so this this is
where those differences lie it's in
those fundamental differences between
the way those factions work so we've
always said that you want
the you've got three game plan how these
games going to interact now now the
total war Warhammer - is nearly upon us
how is going to interact with people who
own - a world war right so so the sort
of basic of it is is you get a new
campaign with with every with every part
of the trilogy so part one you've got
the old world campaign part - you've got
the new world campaigns and the Americas
if you like of the Warhammer world and
the third game again will will will
bring you a new place and new places and
new faces and so you get those
individual campaigns so you can play
those they've the proper big campaigns
but shortly after launching one hammer -
we will be providing as a free update a
sort of ground combined campaign map
which attaches those two parts the world
together and lets you play as any of the
races at your own across either of those
either of those games so your own
Warhammer 1 and your own Warhammer 2 and
you get the combined campaign map and
you won't say the wood elves because
you've got that for what hammer 1 you
can then play them in the ground
campaign and take them right over to
meet their to meet their long-lost
cousins in all four and and nagger off
in the in the in the new world so and
the way it differs is that so as I
explained we've got this this this sort
of narrative drive mechanic leading you
to this cataclysmic end game which which
the vortex represents the great vortex
represents we won't be doing that in the
combined campaign map it's it's it's
pure sandbox and although it still does
have the sort of chaos worried invasion
from the first game it you know we've
decided to keep the vortex out of it
because we want that to be the ultimate
sandbox game you know this is it's like
the holy grail of total war games having
all those factions which is so hugely
different and the other players as any
of them so and that's that we think
that's the best way of going about it
and people seems people seem to be
agreeing so that's I think we do hi you
mentioned the vortex I understand that
that's kind of your new mechanic to
drive the armies forward and drive your
progression kind of kind of a pace
that's you feel like there's always
something lingering behind you yes
exactly and you'll see you'll see that
we've got a specific piece of UI which
tracks the progress of each of
races so if you suddenly see the high
off starting ahead you're like I might
have to kind of break off with what I'm
doing
and go and take them down a peg or two
and lo look they're casting a ritual and
it's you know with and the rituals are
sort of connected to settlements so you
can you can see it happening on the
campaign map and you can go and try and
interfere with in stop them from
performing their ritual and it creates
this tension because it might be driving
you away from you or you're sort of
single-minded I'm expanding in this bit
of territory right now and I really want
to put my resources into developing
these three cities and making a nice
production center over here or something
like that then that happens so it pulls
you away from that and gives you you
know gives you a new and quite quite
time-sensitive and crucial objective
that you know you don't want those guys
to get too far ahead because they could
win the ultimate victory because you
know if they do that if they get that
far ahead you'll lose the game we can
actually have there's a discrete point
at which you can now lose the game I
mean obviously you could lose a total
war game for but that's if you lose your
last settlement and you're out the game
you've been knocked out effectively but
now you can be knocked out by letting
the other races be to the vortex and
similarly you can you can well not not
so much ignore the narrative of that but
you can choose not to engage with it
with with with the great vortex stuff
and if you want and you you think you're
able to and you've got the you know and
you've got the you know the knowledge
and understanding to do it you can
expand your empire and just trying to
story those races and knock them out
before they can do anything with the
vortex so you can still play in the
traditional way it's just that you've
got the extra level of challenge of
they're all they're all driving towards
doing something that you're not
necessarily on that race track with them
you're just trying to smash up the cars
you know so one of the draws was that
you could play these vastly different
races through these campaigns with with
a friend how is the the interaction
between total war 1 & 2 going to change
that if I want to play with my friend he
doesn't own the first game I'm assuming
that you won't be able to really play as
things like the Empire yeah exactly you
need to own both games to get the
combined campaign map that's that that's
that's that's how it works so so if
you've if one of you owns one and one of
you owns one and two then you won't be
able to co-op I mean still be able to
co-op between in the old world with you
with you or because you're on your base
playing the first game
effectively but you access the the
combined campaign map through the second
game okay any understands you've got the
first game so you get the map sounds
like quite a tricky way to organize
things must been quite challenging to
link all this stuff to a MIDI I won't
joke you know I went I won't make any
bones about it is it is a challenge and
it's it's and it's big and it needs a
lot of a lot of time play testing and
balancing you know because it's it's
it's massive
and it's going to get bigger with again
with the third game so so and that's one
of the reasons we're releasing it
slightly later than launch because we
want to give it its own time we needs
time to breathe
and and be tested and be tested and be
tested for more so so yeah we're quite
confident it's going to be tremendous
fun by the end is that going to be a
thing you learn from the first few weeks
of trouble Warhammer 2 you get to see
how the community reacts and plays
before you create that combined campaign
well I'd be honest it won't be too far
off the launch there will be some way
down the road of getting it done by then
but yeah I think there'll be it'll be
useful feedback to see how people are
playing what factions they're preferring
what particular tactics or strategies
they're using which mechanics they're
really involving with more than others
they're really involving themselves in
with more than others so and I think
that's particularly true of someone like
the High Elves because they're quite
they're quite yeah high altar haughty
arrogance and they're very political
creatures so they've got a whole a whole
set of bonus activities though they can
do in diplomacy they can diddle around
with other people's other people's
diplomatic activity so so in some senses
you might want to play the hails and
just be a total total politician about
it and just manipulate all the factions
around you you know when to go into war
with each other and you can't just you
can't just do that Union you mean you
need to you need to gather influence
which is a sort of you know you need
there's certain activities you can do to
go out into the world and you gather
influence so once you're in for this is
increased you can do these things more
and more so you can't just do it ad
infinitum without actually engaging in
the game but but yeah it just means you
can play in a very different way and I
think that's going to be interesting to
see how people you know when the game
comes out see how people play play the
games and see how they focus their
faction
other races too you know to try and
conquer their way through the world so
are you doing some like that your
long-term strategy is it going to be
similar to total war Warhammer one we've
got a mixture of DLC 3lc exactly that
and yeah I understand you've changed
based on community feedback you're
changing your launch add-ons approach
after the chaos warrior yeah well yeah
this time around we decided to try
something different
so we're yeah we're actually releasing a
race pack for Warhammer one so and it's
quite a significant piece of content as
well yeah we you know we we we want
people to feel that the game is complete
when they get it only you know one or
two will have its DLCs as well and it's
free LCS as you mentioned but yeah we
and we spotted an opportunity to do
something that we've been thinking about
but haven't been able to get into
Warhammer one that we think would be a
really good addition as well so so it's
not and it's nice to not just leave the
game behind to know that we can go back
and then still add more to it so yeah I
think it'll it's a yeah it's a new
approach for us definitely and we'll see
how it goes
and surely it's a big win for your
community as well kind of proving that
you're still going to support the game
yep long after launch exactly yeah yeah
yeah and I think I mean it's warhammers
massive like well the more whole world
is big and I think we could be making we
could probably carry on making the games
for years and the game for years and
just keep adding stuff to it so you know
we've we've we've got our we've got our
kind of three game plan with it and
there's there's there's lots of DLC and
free LC you know characters and factions
and all that kind of stuff we we know we
want to add to it but there's still what
to do you know if we wanted to so you
know there's there's I'd say the sky's
the limit to some extent you know now
one question like evolving so one
question I get asked a lot from tour
fans and strategy fans is they asked me
for a reason to get into to talk
Warhammer because the hobby itself and
the law itself is seen as quite
inaccessible what would you would you
say to get them into it yeah um what I'd
want to show them dinosaurs firing
lasers being written good angular Souls
obviously I I think it's just that it's
the diversity the content
and the rich character that each of
these races has and when you you know if
you play Warhammer
you know if you play will have to play
for 2k if you play tabletop games with a
range of you know a range of different
sort of factions you pick one that you
feel you kind of feel you gel with right
so so I play ogres because I quite like
that big and stumpy and the everything
and you know so I'm an ogre player on
the tabletop because I just dig them
other people play other people play
green skins because they like that kind
of kind of jokey like jokey comedy
either and they have an the randomness
of how they work on on the battlefield
and you know that's definitely something
we tried to reflect in the game and I
just think there's there's there's so
many there's so many flags in the game
which you can kind of which you can kind
of hoist as your own as it were that I
think and then there's so much depth to
the there's so much depth to those two
those those races and there's so much
variety in the different army builds you
can go for I just say that it's it's
just a great game you know is it's it's
it offers almost endless diversity and
fun so so you play ogres but I play
Skaven do you and I know at the end of
the trailer there was a rat that looked
other if he was tired but he had the red
eyes and looked a bit Scavo knee I
didn't know what's that one escape what
what what are Skaven you know you want
one open no no I mean you know I've
heard rumors yeah
I've heard rumors um about giant you
know man-sized rats but it's clearly
utter codswallop
so yeah I don't I don't I don't I don't
really know where you want me to go with
this um it's it's like it's like you're
saying that you asked me to believe in a
lie you know as though I'm asking yeah I
think you are I think you are live here
right now asking me to believe in an
urban myth I think it was like teasing
glad I'm in the middle to separate you -
yes I don't not like teasing you so yeah
we'll see it as a colleague of mine said
recently the fourth fourth race in the
game has not yet been ratified interest
right yes interesting choice of words
well I'll thank you so much
the game is playable on the show floor
when can folks home get their hands on
it
September 28th we're out pretty old as
they open now and we talked about you
know what you get for that sand some
great Warhammer one content so yeah
September 28th is the release date and
it's not long to go so we've got we've
still got a bit of work to do but we're
getting there and yeah we're looking
forward to launch awesome awesome well
thank you again
thanks guys make sure you don't go
anywhere we're going to be going back to
the e3 show floor where our pals kind of
funny have special guest Brandon Jones
from easy allies so make sure you don't
go anywhere